my dad told me when I was 19 and I had a
terrible reputation and I was asking him
I said hey how do I change my reputation
how do I get these people to think
differently about me he said why don't
you stop acting like an and your
reputation will catch up with you and so
what I started doing was acting the way
that I thought I wanted my reputation to
be and the beginning no one cared they
treated me the way I used to be but when
the way I was behaving was different
than what they were expecting the way
they saw me started to shift and it took
about 2 years for my reputation to
change but I was really dedicated to
doing it for me rather than doing it for
them and then eventually my reputation
caught up